Sunday statement yeah craft time and I
have the question okay the first
selection in a draft right Dallas kicker
Brett Maher made his second career 60
yard field goal on Sunday
only two other kickers in NFL history
have made multiple 60-yard field goals
in their careers name one of them I'm
gonna go with Jason Elam
who is it Sebastian Janikowski and Greg
the leg except when it's a 44 yarder
against the Seahawks is our line
haha alright I get the first pick I was
good gotten the first pick I don't know
I got it look and here's what we usually
try to do folks Oh peel back the curtain
by the time we get to this point in the
show yeah we try to kind of like clean
up games we haven't addressed and but
you know what the draft is gonna stand
alone yeah somewhere right I got to go
with the 49er yeah it's the total team
effort yeah incredible impressive and
you know Richard Sherman stop it with
the hey if you said we weren't gonna be
any good before the season don't change
now that's not how it works
takes evolved just like teams evolve
takes get better takes get worse
some people are stubborn some people
aren't I'm willing to say I didn't
envision the 49ers to be a playoff team
and I'm willing to say now as I said
last week if they get to five and oh
they're at least gonna be 13 and three
and I'll put my name on it and the 49ers
going to LA taking on a desperate Rams
team that lost two in a row when the
Rams had four extra days to get ready
for this game to stifle them to stymie
them defensively the way they did we
talk about best defenses in the NFL the
49ers are in the top five maybe the top
three there are only two behind I mean
just to further your point Mike I mean
you're exactly right and statistically
okay they're there number two to the New
England Patriots points per game they're
number two the Patriots are letting up
eight points a game the 49ers twelve
point eight points per game
the this New England Patriots two
hundred and thirty four point seven
yards per game the San the San Francisco
49ers two hundred and thirty seven point
four yards per game so they are
phenomenal it is and Mike I'm with you I
mean to me the 49ers have proven to at
least at this point that you know yeah
they're going on the playoffs and I just
I think they're gonna be fighting for a
number one or number two seat at the
very least I would be shocked if any
fights
want I want I know Patriots 49ers
Superbowl yeah that's what I want yeah
because they say what are you root for I
mean and we joke around about the
Vikings fan Giants fan whatever yeah I
like good stories yeah I like stories
that have a lot of tentacles a lot of
angles a lot of different a lot of
different areas for interest and
intrigue and there would be nothing like
a Patriots 49ers Super Bowl because of
Jimmy Garoppolo and Tom Brady because
Tom Brady grew up a 49ers right so much
and so and Kyle Shanahan versus Bill
Belichick no doubt the the the the Jedi
met the aging Jedi Master or whatever
Star Wars
I don't follow Star Wars enough to know
what I've been the Dark Lord right with
the hoodie up and the young Jedi Master
trying to take him down right if I'd
talk about what anyway go ahead that
would be an awesome matchup I mean maybe
then Patriots Saints would be up there
with it too but I'm with you I would
love to see that okay my next one I
think a girl the Houston Texans as far
as statements are concerned you know
Houston I think is one of those teams we
looked at where you go
we know that got the Shaun Watson
offensively a little bit all over the
place to start the year but here we are
you know for the second week in a row
where we go Watson we know is awesome
but the passing offense the offense in
general Billy O'Brien
you know his ability to stay patient
with the run game and do all of that
still gives them a physical mindset and
to go into Kansas City when Kansas City
had just lost the game on Sunday Night
Football and you know they're a little
angry and and the attention to detail is
greater I think was absolutely
phenomenal now I know there was a bad
call against the Kansas City Chiefs that
hurt them I also say this I mean the
Houston Texans dropped about three or
four touchdown passes in the game two
that they left some points on the board
but I just think with JJ Watt okay
Whitney Merciless is better better than
I was expecting them to be this year
there's a lot of things to like with
that Houston Texas football team and
they made a big statement to say hey we
know the Patriots are the kings but we
might be you know for lack of a better
phrase the Queen's in the AFC they're in
that conversation for the second-best
team yeah I agree with you completely
there and the Texans took a lot of
criticism before
the season the trades they made and and
OGM it just felt like a bumbling
operation but they have gotten it
together and right now they are alone at
the top of the AFC South and they play
the Colts this week that should be a
great game yeah all right instead of
picking a team I'm gonna get specific we
gave this guy a little love last segment
I gotta hand it to Lamar Jackson even
though wasn't won only the Bengals
here's the thing right the first
quarterback in the Super Bowl era - in
the regular season have more than 200
yards passing and more than 150 yards
rushing in the same game Colin
Kaepernick once did it in a playoff game
against the 49ers Lamar Jackson was the
first guy to do it
in the regular season he's eighth in the
league in rushing right now he's
averaging 251 passing yards per game I
know he hates to run well you know what
there's a lot of things that people hate
that they're good at he's good at it so
he's doing it and he did it very well
yesterday yeah he did he's phenomenal I
mean I just you know he looks like he's
got a gear faster this year than he did
last year I think that's what's special
and I mean just takes big hits and just
never seems to be phased or get up slow
I mean he is just some wiry twitchy
athlete and remember early last year
what yeah looked like he was heavier yes
right here burst because he felt like he
had to put on maybe some extra armor for
the NFL level now he's looking like that
guy at Louisville definitely they could
just run away from everybody I
definitely I mean his speed is you know
straightaway speed is special and then I
mean look at this he's running over
safeties he's got phenomenal quick feet
I mean I don't think he can make a
living like this forever okay I do want
you to watch your body Lamar Jackson but
man am i proud of you the way you're
playing and throwing the football really
good again good thing they kept him at
quarterback okay next one I'm going to
go to the Steelers front seven yeah I
got to give them a lot of credit the
Steelers front seven won a football game
for that organization last night now
they lost Stefon to it and I'm a little
worried about that because Stefan - it
is one of the best interior Dean linemen
in the NFL and you know I know I heard
Michele Tafoya say it was a pectoral
injury and I hope he didn't tear a PEC
because if he did that'll be it for the
year but regardless they're still going
to be a force to be reckoned with then
your backup is Tyson a lil Alou that's
when you know you're good but man Devin
Busch you know T
jy Casey Heyward you know bud Duprees a
beast Vince Williams at the other middle
linebacker spot we talked about a Lulu
they just got everything and they
dominated Hargrove at nose tackle they
really dominated that Chargers up front
and really they're good enough up front
to you know win games or at least keep
their whole team in games because they
can make life hard on just about any
offense and football I thought they made
a statement last night hey young
quarterback okay great you know get on
our back we'll make things easy for you
yeah and look if the Steelers keep
playing defense that way they are gonna
be a force to be reckoned with
in the AFC North they're two games
behind the Ravens just think what would
how different it would have been if they
could have won that game last week that
was in over life it was a great play by
Marlin Humphrey to knock the ball out
from Judas miss Shuster and and you know
people think it's his fault I mean it's
a great play but but the Steelers could
have won that game and we'd be feeling
very very differently if they don't won
that game I may have picked them to win
last night yeah I'm so mad at that's so
bother geez that's gonna bother you all
we all don't know what though who we
gonna pick next week between the Cowboys
and the Eagles I'm already worrying
about that yeah I can't go to two and
six I mean I know you're at one inside I
know it's horrible
it really it bothered me watching that
game last night I actually had is like
speaking out loud I told my wife I was
like I can't believe I picked the
charges I'm such an idiot I went against
everything I said all right I I we are
only ten or 11 days removed from what
appeared to be an event inevitable
Stefon Diggs exit from Minnesota and and
even though last week it seemed like it
got everything under control he didn't
really produce in the passing game he
didn't get the kind of opportunities it
was an atom's feeling day well yesterday
was a Stefon Diggs day and it was a huge
day for Stefon Diggs seven catches 167
yards three touchdowns the first Viking
since Randy Moss in 2000 to have
multiple 50-yard touchdown receptions in
the same game the one little glitch he
left that that that ball bounced off of
his face and it went up into the air and
Anderson dae-ho picked it off and and it
was during that period of time where it
felt like the Eagles gonna make a game
of it but Diggs was phenomenal and he
happy for now and they're finding
balance in the offense they're using the
run to set up the past not the run to
set up the run yeah and that's what they
had done in a couple of those games
earlier in the year when it was just run
it and run it and run it and even though
the defense is trying to take away the
run they keep running it now they're
passing when a defense is expecting the
run and guys are getting wide open wide
open definitely they got a nice little
formula they really do in cousins
he throws a pretty deep ball and you
know again maybe lack of aggressiveness
early on in the year and left some plays
and was a little off in that bears game
and I get that it's not always an easy
place to play but he's been on fire
since that point and they're finding
yeah the right times like you said to
throw the football in strike and keep
people off of that running game alright
I'm a little torn with this one here I
don't know where to go because I mean
the Seahawks the Panthers they all made
great statements I think I'm gonna go
with the New Orleans Saints so just as a
football team once again I mean I always
really want to just go with Sean Payton
that'sthat's who I'm gonna go with him
making a statement and the like hey I'm
one of the best coaches in football I'm
one of the best head coaches that's been
around for the last 20 years in the NFL
I mean he really is not anybody not
named Bill Belichick I mean I think Sean
Payton's in the conversation for the
next guy in line for who's been the
greatest head coach you know over the
last 10 15 years and you know Sean
Payton his teams are just always tough
they're always physical there they are
in Jacksonville yesterday yeah they came
off a big win last week where Teddy
Bridgewater threw the ball and they beat
the Bucs at home it was very easy to go
into Jacksonville it's not like the most
intimidating environment and kind of
fall asleep Jacksonville is good too
they're no slouch they can run the ball
they can play defense and I just think
Sean Payton once again it's more than
just oh you know we can throw for 5,000
yards you know he can run the football
he knows how to probably inject himself
not and I know I know probably he does
he doesn't inject themselves in the
defensive conversation I give Dennis
outlet a lot of credit to they've
adjusted the way they play but their
defenses picked it up since Drew Brees
has been out and they're just they're
one of those teams that's like hey know
Drew Brees so we're still
damn good and we're in the conversation
for the best team in the NFC yeah I mean
if I want to see 49ers Patriots in the
Super Bowl I want to see 49ers Saints
second in the NFC champion yeah right
that would be great they but those two
teams would kill each other because
their offensive defensive lines are both
top five in football and and that is
another very real factor yeah the
Patriots are gonna potentially have an
easier path then whoever comes out of
the NFC and if it comes out of them see
maybe chewed-up you know nothing left
our game against the Patriots
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports